actualité internationale également je
vous le disais dans les titres c'est une
première depuis le début l'invasion
russe en ukraine un procès pour crimes
de guerre va se tenir contre un soldat
russe de 21 ans il est accusé d'avoir
abattu un civil désarmé et risque la
prison à vie à kiev les précisions de
gulliver crâne notre correspondant
il s'appelle vadim 6,6 marines et un
sergent dans l'armée russe et il est
accusé d'avoir tué un civil un homme de
68 ans dans un village dans le nord de
l'ukraine dans la région de soumis au
moment où les forces russes se battait
en retraite en réalité et si marine avec
deux de ses compagnons ont volé une
voiture ukrainienne et ont essayé de
s'échapper aux forces ukrainienne en
entrant dans un village et à un moment
donné chez simard il aurait tiré sur cet
habitant du village selon les enquêteurs
la mobile si vous voulez pour ces
tueries auraient été parce que seraient
potentiellement était un témoin qui
aurait donné les positions de cyrus qui
était en train de fuir aux forces
l'ukrainienne donc ils ont tué dans le
cadre de leur tentative de fuir aux
forces ukrainienne qui finalement s'est
soldée par un échec puisqu'il est
actuellement en captivité ukrainienne en
même temps que si marine il y a deux
autres soldats qui sont en captivité qui
selon la procureure générale du crâne et
des navets n'édicte ova seront jugés à
bientôt aussi et puis il ya des milliers
d' enquêtes qui sont en cours et des
procès in absentia qui sont proposées
aussi par la procureure